and the Oscar goes to
Shrek Aaron Warner
this is the first Academy Award
nomination and the first hospital her
producer Aaron Warner
Shrek employed state-of-the-art CGI
animation producer Jeffrey katzenberg
said that it will be a benchmark for
about a day or two
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you members of the academy for
inviting us to the party by creating
this category to begin with
Shrek took five years and over 500
people to bring to life so I'm
incredibly honored to be up here on
behalf of the entire team
a special thanks go to John Williams who
originally brought the book uh
williamstige's book to DreamWorks Lori
McDonald who thought it might make a
good animated movie The Amazing
directors Andrew Adamson and Vicki
Jensen are incredible cast Mike Myers
Eddie Murphy Cameron Diaz and John
Lithgow thank you